for over 30 years you've watched him
shine in dramas like husbands and wives
Kinzie and Schindler's List now witness
the franchise that finally paid for Liam
Neeson's kids college education 'he's
taken sudha for movies that are all
about kidnapping where no one uses the
word kidnapped they're going to take you
but people in the apartment and she was
taken mother tonight in these
high-octane spy thrillers that aren't as
smart as bored or as cool as bond but
feature way more feed downs of guys who
look like your uber driver meet Brian
Mills an elite ex-cia agent with a
really bad pension plan I can tell you I
don't have money he has a very
particular set of skills what I do have
a very particular set of skills skills
like scrapbooking photography gift
wrapping junkie rehabilitation and car
detailing I'd rather do it myself on a
little obsessive but most of all he's
got the skills that make him a nightmare
for people who don't want their throats
destroyed Wow
when this family is kidnap I mean taken
Ryan will do whatever it takes to get
them back whether that means stealing
someone's cab stealing someone else's
cab shooting an innocent woman
destroying a Construction Yard
destroying a market destroying a train
destroying a US embassy or making his
daughter toss three live grenades into
the streets of Istanbul set off another
grenade
no one in Europe is safe from Liam
Neeson whoa okay dude relax so before
the release of the third and final taken
aim who re-experience the first take in
where the world's most Irish sounding
American about hi Cola saves the world's
oldest looking teenager from some of the
world's hairiest criminals then since it
was way more successful than anyone
expected watch them pull a hangover and
do the exact same thing for taken to
where the world's oldest looking
teenager saves the world's Irish newest
American quite a new economy from the
most interesting man in the world
stay pinched for my friends so enjoy
these two films that confirm every
overprotective dad's worst fears and
show off every ugly stereotype we have
about foreigners while sending Americans
everywhere an important message don't go
to Europe
starring Darkman fancy Jensen Kim Bauer
traitorous Frenchman Eastern European
criminal number one Eastern European
criminal number two Eastern European
criminal number three Eastern European
criminal number four Eastern European
criminal number you get the idea and
Liam's Nissan took in what is this
it's u2's European tour dates she left
the country to follow you to around uh
I'd rather be taken be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers hey screen
junkies do you love movies as much as we
do then check out newbies on break where
you can watch tons of full-length movies
for free on break.com or any of breaks
free mobile apps click the link in the
description below to start watching and
tell him screen junkie sent you
Kegel dinkle jingle big one ring to rule
them all I'm she polishes mcpeck but
you're smelly pirate hooker in your next
video feed me multiple corn dogs I will
find you and I will kill you